Canada hi Melba hey Jonathan how are you
good thank you you are both so fantastic
in the crown you know when that trailer
first dropped it's it's one of the most
emotional trailers I've seen for any
film or series Jonathan what are you
looking forward to when it comes to what
the fans are going to see this season
oh god
um
I'm
hoping that they're going to share of
what I felt when I saw most of the
episodes of the Season which was uh I I
think it's going to be one of the most
exciting Seasons it's certainly for the
royal family one of the most tumultuous
Seasons when a lot of things happened
um and uh
yeah I I can't wait for people to see it
to be honest so it's I'm
as I
I use the word Joy at the end of seeing
the couple of episodes I saw that I felt
joy and I also felt great pride in the
in the series uh something I don't often
feel but I did
I love hearing that uh Melba you were
just so fantastic as the queen and
really interesting that you had the
chance to meet King Charles and Queen
Elizabeth II years before signing on for
this series what was that moment like
for you
um it was obviously some you know at an
event that you know we've seen met them
at various Charities or whatever
um and what's interesting I think when
you go into a room or you're in a room
and they walk in it's how everyone else
behaves into the room and Shake
someone's hands but everyone sort of
just does that and I and uh so that I
found that interesting
um so uh as we said on stage there's no
point you can't be a king or a queen if
the other people don't bow so
um then also we've got Peter Morgan's
writing you've got the real events that
he hangs his imagine scenes on so um
it's it's a rich it's a rich world that
we're living in at the moment
absolutely you know this series is so
well done every single performance is
spectacular so believable so much so
that Dame Judy Dench has suggested
putting a disclaimer before every single
episode just so people know that every
moment isn't historically accurate
Jonathan what do you make of those
comments I think it's a tribute to the
show that uh Judy thinks people will
think it's it's real life
um that and it's it is a tribute that
what you're watching could possibly have
happened but I think people have uh you
know we're now into the fifth season if
if the world doesn't know that it's a
drama and not a documentary where we're
doing something wrong
um so yeah I
absolutely yeah I understand that uh
Imelda were you able to get a chance to
speak with Olivia Coleman or Claire Foy
obviously you played the queen in
earlier uh seasons of the crown before
taking on this part no um because we we
we're all playing the queen and at
different times in their lives and the
only people that we need to talk need to
look at was the real queen and I'm sure
they did the same so
um and and also in a way we are riding
on
Claire and Olivia's success we're riding
on that
um but otherwise I feel if you're
talking to two actors about how then do
for you to do your part you're diluting
the process you just need to go back to
the beginning back to the real person
and um and go from there
what is one of your favorite things that
you learned about the queen when going
back to beginning when learning so much
about her life
um I didn't know how much her faith
meant to her
um and that she was extremely religious
and and I think she gained an enormous
amount of strength from her faith which
she needed from the moment she became
Queen
um and and and I because you think how
did she do that for several times day in
and day out she made a promise she felt
she was anointed
this is a vocation and she was not going
to say I'm a bit tired I think I'll uh
no you absolutely do your duty you said
you're going to do it you do it